danach gilt mein name ist luca meine
damen und herren vor einigen monaten
habe ich bereits auf die hilf mir
rapperin schlechthin reagiert und zwar
auf chris elliott es richtiger scheint
er wird durch ein
ja das war eminem und tupac in einer
person quasi allerdings meine lieben
freunde heute reagieren wir auf das
video auf pcl jetzt burger bude stadt
rap business bevor wir uns das video
allerdings angucken schauen wir erst mal
kurz in die kommentare will ich das
sehen nein muss sich das sehen nein
mache ich es trotzdem ja will rapperin
seien aber kann sich keine zweite
jogginghose leisten in germany we say
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
unnötig wie ein fundbüro in polen ich
bin vor fremdscham fast gestorben alter
hartung eine durchsage meine damen und
herren das niveau wird in den nächsten
13 minuten tiefer als die titanic sinken
wir bitten um ihr verständnis ja
also wie gehen wir mit den höchsten
erwartungen die heutige reaktion sich
mehr leben sie bis sie gibt sich mehr
das war doch das sternchen star himmel
der rap sowieso fokus rücken kann und
sohn alle diese voll kreis rappen carlo
sohn alles ist andreas berg helene
fischer ist nur männliche pillen gab
klar die kann echt super rappen
sie war einfach keine zeit lebens
erzählen im bürgerladen joggen mit
bisschen kohle verdienen kann ok
oh jetzt sie hat kein geld mehr dort
immer eine spendenaktion starten für pc
elliott also klar klimaschutz und so
wichtig aber pc elliott rap karriere
geht klar vorn
[Musik]
krank dass er genau weiß wie viele fans
wie hat
[Musik]
er hat hier ein video von ihr selbst auf
einem handy gezeigt und jetzt denkt sie
an ich bin alles klar
ich brauche das gar nicht dieser
wildfremde typ kommt halt wirklich
einfach haben sie spezielle beim müll
aufsammeln sagt die raiders 500 fenster
guckt auch hier das video sie sieht das
video denkt sich ja wat jetzt bin ich
hab echt also jetzt muss ich ja wirklich
nicht merken genau ich bezahle ich nicht
um ihre pause zu machen sondern um
sauber zu machen und sie zu braucht ganz
ehrlich wer denkst du du bist ja was
soll denn das
ich glaube der ist der chef trägt und
[Musik]
sie beleidigt einfach ihren chef job
gegeben hat und sagt du spielst du den
müll dahin sagt bevor wir uns bisher
erlebt gleich weiter anschauen möchte
ich allerdings wieder ein bild auf
install anzeigen auf dem ich markiert
wurde
und zwar ist es dass er von youtube
unterstrich xd ich seh nix mehr luca 23
steht bei ebbe an der nordsee also wenn
ihr bock auf mehr solcher - habt folgt
auf jeden fall dieser seite auf
instagram und verlinkt mich auf euren
bildern wenn ihr in der nächsten folge
anschauen dort bekommen wollt ihr
beck ich bin um 18.00 uhr ist ganz
europa schaut für alena alias busy
elliott ist klar sie will als rapperin
groß rauskommen
[Musik]
wenig später die jungs wollen über pci
elliott an came on rankommen
die achtjährige tag denn ihre fiese
falle die diese komischen jungs mit
denen sie sich jetzt trifft die wollen
über bis die eltern ran kommen
natürlich
[Musik]
woher ich nach jeder infektion
yao ist krasser finde das ist wenn ja
schon im video sehen es richtig dazu
müssten sie bekommen den kontakt
ok also die erste frage direkt stellen
ist hey wie bist du eigentlich an kay
one rangekommen machtkämpfe und
eigentlich doch was meine videos gesehen
lernt kraft direkt angerufen was
also ich bin
gegenteil eines kay one fans aber er der
doch nicht angerufen also etwas zu
rauchen
ja das was dabei gerade habe ich nichts
zu weinen
du hast nichts dabei du hast du denkst
du musst es dabei haben gamestar
rapperin die müssen immer immer wissen
die drogen dabei haben sagt immer was
dabei erträge machst schreibt
jetzt ist ihr bis einen giftigen die
stimmung gerade aufgekommen
bis die elliott willen rettet gegen
diesen berg opel davon den also ich bin
gespannt am nächsten tag bis sie braucht
dringend geld und will es im bürgerladen
nochmal versuchen
die boa die braucht geld weil sie ja das
marihuana glaube ich damit bringen
sollten rattle oder grün sie sich
erstmal sie möchten wir hier arbeiten es
will eine zweite chance
um ehrlich zu sein können sie hilfe
brauchen
vest
er war warum setzt sich denn die
kollegen auf einmal so für die einheit
checkte gar nichts mehr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die beleidigt wieder
sie hat halt war
jedoch glaube ich nur socken an oder wo
meine karriere wird sowas von steil nach
oben gehen er und dieser scheiss bälger
land ist sowieso doch was für user er
okay ja wann kommt denn jetzt das
kapital nicht mehr reden wenn ich mir
diese kaka anschauen
[Musik]
das ist
der wehr
dagegen
ja wie sie jetzt gegen den werden rap
battle los geht die kleine kammer wegen
dir ist mein nachbar immer wieder was du
brauchst deine mitschke dann kriegst du
jetzt ein trick hier habe ich keine zeit
körper schon die vorschlug fährt deshalb
hat mich die ticker an dem blog
ja ich bin gespannt wie bisher diese
geistige fitness kontern kann ich mit
dem model einen abschluss zu trotzdem
tombazis hier wartet mal hier ist eine
umfrage der ist krasser
ich würde sagen ja hat pc ist immer noch
drauf sie hatte es nie drauf ich muss
sagen so schlecht ist sie ja gar nicht
aber weißt du was jetzt viel mehr biss
und hast du ein bisschen am start
die fragen
marihuana und ich glaube das passierte
nichts dabei weil sie ja pleite
mitbringen hier ist ja gerade alles tut
was es ging
ich habe produzent ich habe meine erste
platte raus und ich hab ich kenne mich
sehr guten die und business und ich kann
dir sehr viel beibringen
[Musik]
bis die elliott kommt da an rap gegen so
einen bären und dann sagt der berner du
bist ja gar nicht so kacke aber jetzt
erst mal eine rauchen oder sap aber
nichts hat bei der trasse der b richtig
aus aber dann sagt er ich gehe aber bald
ins studio und bringen eine plastik raus
ich kann die wirklich was beibringen und
die reaktion von pc elliott ist einfach
klasse ja ich werde mir das gar nicht
weiter anschauen
er kam noch eine halbe minute stopp
stopp stopp stopp stopp lassen los
[Musik]
sid
ich hatte mit diesen komischen cloud
verein der auf dem skateplatz
anzuschauen und haben vorgespräche
nächsten szene wo man bis jetzt allein
mit diesen bären gesehen hat dann
küssten sie auf einmal rum auf dem bett
und jetzt will sie die maske von dem
typen abziehen dann gesagt nein man
sieht meine maske nicht alle die die
abgezogen haben sind jetzt rot völlig
normal unterstellt dass heute wieder
sage ich auch brandon meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese hilfe in
reaction von mir immer wieder gefallen
hat dann das gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem video ihr da schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare
auf welches video ich als nächstes
reagieren soll abonniert meinen kanal
damit ihr das dann nicht verpasst und
jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]